hi friends welcome back to the modern
wisdom podcast my guest today is a
fellow podcaster that Eliason is the
host of made you think and also the man
behind growth machine comm I had a few
things that wanted to speak to NAT about
today
his ability to retain the information
that he reads in books through a
progressive summarization method is
pretty impressive and he takes us
through that today he also explains how
he's managed to essentially monetize his
passion by selling access to his own
Evernote we talk about growth machine
comm and how organic versus paid
strategies in the online world are
changing and developing over time and
finally he gives us his five favorite
books that you probably haven't read so
stay until the end and find out exactly
what not thinks you should sink your
teeth into as your next read which you
might not have seen on the New York
Times bestsellers list please welcome
the wise and wonderful gnat Eliza
[Music]
I'm joined by the host of the made you
think podcast and the man behind growth
machine calm not a liason not welcome to
the show thanks for having me on excited
to be here so I am a big fan of your
podcast recently had Robert Greene on
talking about laws of human nature and
your guys summary of that was a big big
help in prepping it's a big old book and
what you guys do on the podcast really
really helps to condense stuff down
would you be able to explain sort of
what the made you think podcast is and
and what the concept behind is yeah made
you think started actually out of
another podcast so I had mmm I had a
podcast before called nat chat where i
was a good name yeah a great name right
i I was interviewing people who had come
out of college and done something sort
of like a typical and by a typical I
meant you know not gone to do what I saw
a lot of other people from top tier
schools doing like working in finance or
consulting or going work at one of the
fan companies things like that so
talking to a lot of young people who
either went entrepreneurial routes or
we're doing like contract work or ended
up being an early member in an agency
things like that with that you don't
hear about as much when you are going to
some of these schools and trying to get
more of those stories out there for
people who felt like oh those typical
career paths just aren't as exciting to
me so did then it was doing that chat
for a while and interviewed one of my
friends Neil who ended up doing like a
whole bunch of different things right
out of college and eventually became
sort of like a internal innovation
consultant for Estee louder and then
went on to start his own like beer
company helping people create like
custom brews taking advantage of the
unused capacity of breweries around the
country
we had a really good like three hour
long episode just talking about
everything and how he ended up doing
what he was doing and people really
really liked how in depth we went how
much stuff we talked about and then we
said or we thought it might be fun to do
a second episode on a book that we both
really liked Angie fragile by Nassim
Taleb and so we just got back on and
talked about anti fragile for two hours
or so and it ended up being I think the
most popular episode of nat chat ever
and we kind of saw that we're like well
this is clearly a sign that there's
something interesting here and I was
getting a little tired of doing the
interview style of episodes so we said
well why don't we just try doing a
podcast based on reading you know
tougher books and then talking about the
key takeaways from them and so we did
that and started putting out episodes
about books that we were both reading
and enjoying and yeah and that was sort
of the inception for for made you think
yeah I have to say that you're right and
one of the things that you touched on in
the Robert Greene podcast you guys said
that flipping over to the interview
style or maybe it was one of you are the
recent ones flipping over to the
interview style of podcast was something
that you think there's enough people
doing that in that space already and I
have to agree I have a bunch of co-hosts
that I do the show with the listeners
will be familiar with Johnny and Youssef
and the episodes that I do with those
guys by far outstrip the engagement that
the ones that I do even if I get New
York Times bestselling author on and I
think it's something to do with the fact
that when you just have normal candor
between a group of friends a big
proportion of people who are into
podcasting just like that kind of
voyeuristic fly-on-the-wall type stuff
but you're right you you guys have
tackled some pretty difficult books
didn't you tackle there's a absolute
I've got cued up isn't it like some
ridiculously difficult sci-fi book
Infinite Jest yeah yeah it's it's I
guess it's a sci-fi book technically but
yeah it's a super super weird like
thousand page book with 200 pages of
endnotes like most of it makes very
little sense without reading it very
carefully it's it's not quite like
Ulysses level of confusing but it's up
there so that was that was a journey
getting through that book that episode
came together surprisingly well I wasn't
sure exactly what we were gonna talk
about I don't think either of us were
because like nothing really there's no
like huge plot driving the book it's
it's really a character novel but it was
fun to work through it honestly I think
the satisfaction isn't having finished
it not necessarily in all the time spent
reading it's a good one yeah I guess
that's probably the same as doing a
marathon like there's big bits of a
marathon that you probably not going to
enjoy but once you get across the finish
line it feels pretty good yeah exactly
everyone wants to have run a marathon
not to run a marathon yeah perfectly
correct so one of the first things that
I wanted to ask you about was your
approach to progressive summarization
that's what Thiago Forte would refer to
as or I guess in more common parlance it
would be how do you remember the things
that you read I know that you have a
Evernote system and you also have like a
memberships or back-end to your Evernote
which I think's really super interesting
so yeah if you could talk to us about
your process for remembering the things
you read and then also explain to the
listeners about your Evernote your
little Evernote hustle you've got going
on yeah and to be clear you know I
didn't come up with this system at all
this is Thiago's invention and if anyone
isn't familiar with Thiago's work you
should check it out it's a forte labs
like fo RTE labs co-ceo and his blog is
praxis dot for Tait labs Co and he's
really I think one of the only writers
in the productivity space who's worth
reading
pretty much all productivity writing is
just like the same trash being rehashed
a dozen different ways his is actually
novel and interesting and ultimately
much more useful than most everything
else out there so that's a big activity
ah go yeah no I and I stand by that I
really him and Chris sparks are the only
two people who I read in the
productivity space anymore
everybody else is not really
contributing anything newer useful to
the discussion but they're doing good
work so and Chris's at the forcing
function comm interests so yeah we had
to I actually had Tiago on about three
weeks ago we had him on talking
wonderful talking about the digital
productivity pyramid but the final
question I asked him the question about
progressive summarization and that was
as his buzzer went that he had to go
onto something else so I thought let's
let's see what happens if we get into
the trenches with someone who does
progressive summarization a pretty
pretty high velocity and and that's
that's you yeah yes so I it as a way to
consolidate and make my book notes in
particular more useful so whenever I'm
reading a book all pretty much always
read it on my Kindle and all the
highlighting stuff as I'm going so I'm
just using the Kindle highlight feature
anything that looks kind of interesting
I'll highlight so that I can pull it out
later and all sometimes highlight other
things mostly just as gold or signposts
for context when I'm looking back at my
notes later I read most nonfiction now
with the notes that I'm going to take
from them in mind so it's very like
strategic consumption to do it in a way
where I know I'm gonna get good notes
out of the book that I can use later so
I'm going through and I'm highlighting
the things that are interesting and
standout and then when I'm done I use a
tool called read wise read wise calm
that can take your Kindle highlights and
then seamlessly export them to Evernote
with all of the formatting and stuff
coming out really cleanly so it's just
you know highlight highlight highlight
highlight and new lines with know like
weirdness that you
the other apps so I'll take it all into
Evernote and then it's got this kind of
like disorganized list of my highlights
from the book and then I'll go back
through and first all like add whatever
other signposting I need so whether
that's section titles or chapters or
however else up in a struct for the
notes so that I can skim through them
easier later and then the progressive
summarization comes in which is going
through and adding anywhere from three
to four layers it's two to four layers
of annotation to the note in order to
make the highlights from the book even
more useful so in its base form it's
just your highlights it's just the text
they hold out of the book layer two is
going through and bolding the parts of
those highlights that is most important
so you might have you know part of each
highlight that's most important you
might have some less that are less
important this is usually the phase
where all go through and delete some of
them too yeah like maybe I highlighted
an idea early on in the book and then
later on that idea got explained better
and so I'll keep the highlight from
later and delete the one from earlier so
I do a bit of cleanup there and then
once you've gone through and bolded all
the important parts then you go through
again and you highlight the most
important parts of the bolded parts so
you're only reading the text that you've
bolded you're ignoring all the unfolded
text you're going through the bolded
text Knar saying okay of this what is
the most important and you're
highlighting that so that now when you
skim through your note you've got these
highlighted call-outs of the most
important where's the book that you can
easily jump to to pull out those ideas
and then there's another layer that I
don't always do I think Yahoo does a
better job of it but if you keep coming
back to a certain book or a certain note
you can create like a little executive
summary at the top of the note and so
that's just like maybe three to five
bullet points of the most important
ideas from the book or from the article
whatever you took the notes from so that
you can really quickly read I jest what
you took away from that piece when
you're coming back to it now I do this
differently from Thiago where Thiago his
method or the way he does it is like as
a book or an article gets resurfaced so
as he meets something for an article
he's writing or it comes up in a
conversation then he might bring up the
note and then each time he brings it up
he does another layer so he doesn't
immediately go through and bold things
he waits and then when it comes up again
he'll go through and bold it released
this is how I remember how he said he
did it what I do is I do it I do it all
upfront after I've read the book because
as you alluded to I have a product on my
site where I sell these notes so I've
been doing it and I was doing it in a
rougher form before I discovered
Thiago's work where I was just pulling
out my highlights and organizing them
and publishing them as pages on my blog
similar to what Derek Siver's does and
then as I you know got into Tiago's
working learn about progressive
summarization I started doing that's all
my book notes so now I've got I think
like 240 books in there and they're all
annotated and highlighted and everything
so it makes it really quick for me to go
back through and pull out the most
important takeaways yeah 241 bucks so
and then I just sell that on my blog and
you pay $50 and you get lifetime access
to all current and future notes that go
in there which is pretty useful if
you're trying to decide you know what
book to read or if you know you read a
book but you didn't take any notes you
want to go back and pull out some
important stuff I've got a lot of like
the popular ones in there including laws
of human nature of course and yes auntie
Fraggle and all the ones on on made you
think so yeah that's sort of how that
all started and then the other fun thing
with it is since I publish a less
annotated version of these notes on my
site my site actually ranks in Google
for the titles of a lot of these books
or if you search a lot of these books
plus summary or plus highlights you'll
usually find my blog on the first page
so if you google like 48 laws of power
or summary I think I'm like in the top
three that come up for that and that you
know but a lot of traffic to the site
and then people discover my other
articles they discover the
paid burning of the notes so it's a nice
little like bit of side passive income
for sure yeah it's um it's cool that
you've taken something there's this of
evolution of ideas or evolution of
process that we've got here where
previously you were taking notes then
you refined your process of taking notes
through Thiago's course then that became
that form the foundation for you to then
build the podcast off because I'm gonna
guess when you're recording made you
think all that you really do is go back
through your notes for the particular
book that you're talking about and move
through there and you've got that as
your reference and then you've created a
income stream off that also you're
driving traffic off that it's like the
ultimate evergreen content I suppose
yeah yeah in many ways and then
obviously when I'm doing my like other
articles that might reference stuff in
one of these books I've got all my
highlights right there so that I can
just go back and pull out whatever
sections I want to quote for my articles
so it's really useful for creating other
content as well
I got you so how do you choose what you
want to read you've mentioned you've got
you know 240 books which is summarized
so I'm gonna guess you a live read more
than that which haven't been summarized
and you seem to read a pretty quick
click pace how do you choose what it is
that you're going to dedicate your time
to it's sort of just whatever I'm
interested in or if it's made you think
related it's whatever Neil and I want to
do an episode on there's not that much
science behind it honestly because I
know the the biggest impediment to
reading a lot will just be reading stuff
that I don't want to read because if I
get you know into a book that I don't
that I'm not that interested in then
I'll just get stuck and like do other
things instead so I just gotta go with
whatever is interesting to me at the
time and read that yet bizarre that kind
of inertia occurs when you are reading a
book that you don't want to read I know
that Navarre and Joe Rogan on the
podcast that they did recently spoke
about the fact that neither of them
actually finished books I think novels
like notorious for just picking up a
book reading a page finding something he
likes
and then going down a rabbit hole on
like Wikipedia and searching blogs for
the rest of the night but for me
personally I find it's a bit of an open
loop when I've got a book that so
Thinking Fast and Slow is a perfect
example and it's like it's so long as
well it's a it's a monster to get
through I just I've really struggled to
get through that book and I keep on
trying and keep on picking it up keep on
picking it up and every time I do my
overall reading for the week goes down
because I just there's something like I
don't know whether it's because I don't
to be defeated and whether I just want
to kind of grit my teeth and continue to
read through it but you you're very
correct if there's listeners at home who
are trying to develop a reading habit I
have been and continue to at the moment
over the the coming years hopefully that
will get more and more easy for me is it
the trajectory is suggesting but yeah
the getting bogged down in the book is a
surefire way to make reading an awful
lot harder yeah and I think that people
will sweat too much early on about you
know reading good books or challenging
books but it's like get in the habit of
just like reading anything first and
then you can level up the difficulty as
you go right you don't want to be
reading business ebooks right like James
all teacher trash for too long but if
you need to start there like there's
nothing wrong with that
yeah and especially before before bed
sometimes for me if I do end up reading
something that's to kind of go get it
and upward mobility focused I end up
going to bed in my mind absolutely
buzzing so I think there's definitely a
place in there for people to read I
don't know like autobiographies or
fiction or you know more narrative based
stuff I guess to kind of just give give
your brain a little bit of a rest
definitely yeah so tell us about growth
machine I'm super interested to hear
about that yes a growth machine is a SEO
focused content marketing agency so we
work with e-commerce and tech companies
to take over
decent portion of their blog and their
content strategy to get them you know
ranked top of Google for everything
related to their product and their
customers interests so well you know I
think the best example of this is our
work on our own site cup and leaf which
is a ecommerce tea store and then we've
created little cup and leaf blog talking
about tea and managed to get in the top
spots on Google for like best green tea
best oolong tea health benefits of
jasmine tea like all of those terms and
then that search traffic translates
directly into the sales that you're
getting organically instead of having to
buy ads on the terms yeah so the organic
versus paid debate is one that we
continue to have on this podcast North a
lot the two co-hosts a big proponents of
paid funds of some ovens and of the guys
behind clickfunnels and the that kind of
I guess how would you call it the more
transactional approach to to driving
traffic but certainly agree and I think
that organic if you can get it right is
such a powerful tool yeah and it doesn't
have to be an either/or yeah you know
they usually support each other and
organic is slower and more difficult and
takes longer to kick in but if you can
get it right you know you can
potentially be getting ongoing customers
for almost free right like yeah it it
can work very very well if you know how
to target the right things but it's much
harder especially in the early days to
build a business on because again it is
so slow whereas you can just turn on ads
tomorrow and if you know what you're
doing start making start making sales
within a week yes driving traffic it is
it's it's one of these things I wouldn't
know what your thoughts are on this
coming out from someone who does push to
the optimization of SEO my concern with
the proliferation of paid media at the
moment of paid advertising
that essentially anybody can do it if
it's just a formula and Rory Sutherland
was on the podcast talking about this as
well and he said that he thinks Silicon
Valley sees everything is an
optimization problem and that they
presume that if you get the correct
combination of numbers on a spreadsheet
the output will be a black figure at the
bottom of your balance and I don't know
for me there has to be diminishing
margins of return is more and more
people find like more and more people
read expert secrets by Russell Brunson
or whatever whatever their Bible of
choice for online advertising is that
particular strategy will get rinsed and
rinsed down to the point at which so
many people are doing it that the market
won't respond any more what what your
thoughts on that yeah maybe I mean ads I
think have always been here and always
will be here and they will just change
how they're being presented to us like
most of the money now is going into
Instagram ads instead of Facebook ads
obviously it's still Facebook but
there's people are getting better ROI on
Instagram now because Facebook ads are
kind of played out and maybe that will
change over time like maybe more will
move into Pinterest or somewhere else
but I don't think it's ever gonna get so
saturated that it no longer works you
just have to keep getting better at it
and there will probably always be
interesting new areas to check out but I
think it's just like as long as people
are selling things online there's gonna
be ads and if you're good you're gonna
make a lot of money and if you're bad
you're yeah I totally totally agree so
going back to the books and the content
that you've been consuming over the last
few years some of the listeners may be
thinking that I'm pretty interested in
getting stuck in have you got a top 5 or
so that you could run us through it
doesn't need to be of all-time it could
just be what you've thought of recently
or anything like that but I think some
recommendations might be cool and then
we could have a little discuss about
each of the books perhaps yeah top books
almost read what do you keep going back
to oh I read very
rarely because I just take good enough
notes the first time that I don't need
to go reread it exam of course you did
for the most part so I I'm gonna I'm not
gonna pick the best five per se I'm
gonna try to pick a few that maybe
haven't been talked about on here as
much because I can make some guesses
about what has probably come up before
so piqued by Anders Ericsson Robert
Poole is probably the best book on
learning and skill acquisition way way
more useful than any of the like hack
e-learning stuff like Tim Ferriss style
books that I think are more popular I
think peek is actually a legitimately
useful one for learning for somebody
with a more long-term mindset is that a
prescriptive book oh I haven't I haven't
read it uh it's not prescriptive I mean
the things they're not trying to sell
you that you're going to be able to like
learn a language in 24 hours so they're
much tempered and how they frame things
but it's very prescriptive if you know
how to read and implement it go I've got
them Scott H Jung I've got him on this
week talking about ultra learning which
is his new book and he references peek
in that he references make it stick by
Peter C Brown who's been on this podcast
as well and atomic habits as well I
suppose but yeah the kind of desire for
people to learn how to learn definitely
identifies that most people don't know
which is bizarre right considering
almost everyone in the Western world's
in full-time education for at least like
11 years or something yeah yeah but it's
still a solo challenge and I think the
other thing too that people need to be
careful about is that all of this like
learning how to learn skill acquisition
stuff a lot of it is sort of a
get-rich-quick scheme in disguise and
how so like the old well because people
think like oh I could just like you know
or one they think that's the problem
isn't that learning is hard it takes a
while it's that I'm like doing it
incorrectly right and so instead of just
continuing
to make progress in the way that they
probably should they look for hacks and
they look for shortcuts and like they
get obsessed over the whole 8020
nonsense and like think they need to
over optimize their process instead of
just like doing the work and getting not
good at the skill like skill acquisition
is really simple like it's not
complicated but people who are
complicated
like one to sell stuff into because it's
more fun to like spend time trying to
hack your learning than it is to do the
boring learning stuff right like you
feel super productive rereading you know
like an article on how to learn and you
feel like you're making progress but
it's like no you should probably just if
you're trying to learn a language like
you should be speaking to someone in
that language and literally anything
else you are doing is a waste of time
right yeah Agrippa son the principle of
the principle of directness yeah and I
think it's just like you got to be
careful with all of the stuff that is
trying to sell you that you can learn
things like crazy quickly because nobody
who's good at anything like learned it
really quickly and if you're trying to
like find the 20% to get to 80% well
anybody else can do that so the 80% is
really like the 50% and it's not really
good enough for anything besides writing
about in blog articles like it looks
super sexy yeah and I think as well have
you listened to the novel and Joe Rogan
podcast yet no not yet oh now you got to
get on it man it is like I don't usually
sort of fanboy of a podcast episodes but
that one was was a real like just mic
drop after mic drop throughout the
entire podcast really good and in that
novel talks about the fact that people's
desire to look clever is greater than
their desire to be clever and I think
that what you've alluded to there which
is someone wanting to know enough to
have a simulacrum of intelligence and I
find it in myself right like you know I
want to be on this podcaster I'm I'm
gonna speak to Robert Greene New York
Times best seller world renowned author
and I want to say stuff that makes me
sound like I'm
not a different species to him like
Alice all right
I wanna sound like you know he's got so
he chris has got some interesting stuff
to say but it the lack of humbleness
pulls you away from the actual thing
that you're trying to do which is just
to understand stuff yeah no I think
that's very true
so yes what's what we got next I'll peek
up first and then it was very good I'll
say endurance by Alfred Lansing is very
good all right so that's the story of
Shackleton and his crew who were trying
to do the first trans Antarctic crossing
and end up getting stuck in the ice
right at the beginning of the trip and
have to survive for I think like almost
two years in Antarctica with no
additional supplies or anything to you
and yeah and everybody like everybody
outside of them just as soon as they
were dead because they never made it to
their check-ins yeah and every single
member of the crew survived the whole
like expedition and rescue mission it's
an absolutely insane book so that's
highly recommend that's probably like my
favorite biography I've read it's really
really incredible that's awesome
have you read it's gonna so man's search
for meaning is one book I guess that
kind of comes to mind with regards to
that like turmoil and people going
through things but the Forgotten
Highlander or the last Highlander I
think it is by Alistair no I haven't
heard that so this man if you if you
need a new order biography style book to
read I really highly recommend this one
so this guy was a Scottish recruit in
the Highlanders Regiment World War two
placement placed overseas in Japan and
then when the Japanese took I decided
that they were going to invade and
actually enter the war
he was taken prisoner he basically had
dysentery for like four years straight
worked on bridge over the river kwai was
left out in a hot tin box for two days
with no food or water to basically cook
in the Sun yeah man it's like it's like
man's search for meaning but extreme
then he gets taken to a different a
completely different camp has to be
hospitalized number of times they're not
getting not giving anyone any care get
to put on one of these death ships which
is like basically a tin a tin can
floating out at sea then then start
working gets transferred somewhere else
gets starts working on a new bridge and
gets hit by the blasts of the bomb from
Nagasaki and survived that as well and
then stays silent stay silent for 40
years and it's kind of I guess I can
memoir it's also a call to arms to a
call to account the Japanese government
for the atrocities because there was the
Germans were held to account but I think
I don't think the Japanese were so much
but as is evident by allister's book
there's some pretty big sort of scary
things that went on but yeah that is
like really it's a easy read as well
it's very narrative base but like if you
ever want to have contrast in your life
and just to think like um so I'm so
fortunate to just have a drink whenever
I want a drink and two legs that work
and like bowels that stay inside of my
body yeah yeah it's yeah so what's next
grace that's two let's see next I'll say
sovereign individual by James Dale
Davidson and William Reece mark that's
really really really phenomenal books
it's really really phenomenal book I
think like it will change how you think
about government and individual autonomy
so it and money
and power and a lot of things it's I
think when it came out it didn't get
that much play but it's having a moment
now because it basically predicted a lot
of stuff that's going on in crypto and
the crypto economy so it's really big in
like the Bitcoin fanboy space but it's
like it's a legitimately fantastic book
and you will I think think about
government and individual sovereignty
differently coming out of it the it's a
little like dry and hard to read at time
so you may want to listen to the mate
you think episode first just to see if
it's like interesting before you try to
force yourself through it but it's very
good go at you again thinking about
going back to the novel and your Rogan
podcast you can tell have listened to it
twice in the last the last few days it's
all I've got my mind but he's talking
about the future of social media and how
the process for crypto the
decentralization of crypto has paved a
way for future technologies to proof
themselves against being taken down and
he talks about he predicts that at some
point in the future you will have a
decentralized social networks where it
can't there's no one site or there's no
one host and it can't be taken down and
it will be a little bit more like the
Wild West and and stuff like that so I
think people thinking forward to this
sort of stuff to understand individual
sovereignty and obviously that's Jordan
Peterson's whole shtick right and he's
sold like millions of books off the back
of that this year yeah you know I hope
that's right but I think the humans tend
towards collectivization and monopoly
and centralization not decentralization
like I think that deep down people would
prefer decentralized models for things
or sorry I think on the surface people
say they want decentralized models for
things but the revealed preferences
always trend toward centralized like IIb
I'm kind of I'd be very surprised if we
actually get
the hyper decentralized world that a lot
of the crypto community and it sounds
like navall are prophesizing because
like you will inherently have
disparities in power and any like
collection of power is going to result
in like centralization of control within
that power right and like it's up coming
at you yeah the idea you would have like
a perfectly communist ik distribution of
power and responsibility is just like
kind of ridiculous and I mean people
talk about crypto as if it's the super
decentralized currency but like most of
the power is controlled by like a few
companies in China right like if they
wanted to turn off all of the mining
rigs like they could do that and I'm
sure that BIC ones survived but it's not
like it's this perfectly distributed
thing there's still a collection of
power and there will always be a way to
get powers so I'm skeptical that we're
gonna have this amazing decentralized
future I think we're just gonna change
who holds the power like we always have
yeah I have to say I think there's too
much reptilian brain in a lot of humans
for this idealistic future to occur in
my opinion I would agree with you I
wonder whether people deep down perhaps
like the idea of that centralization
because the way that they've grown up is
with a trust in the institution and you
grow up and you have trust in school you
have trust in your teacher you have
trust in the education system that moves
you on you have trust in law enforcement
you have trust in government and really
no matter how much no matter how much of
an anarchist people someone may claim to
be I think deep down we all would much
prefer government to work the way that
government's supposed to work and
education to work the way that education
supposed to work I don't know whether
that's because people don't have the
ability to see outside of that box or
whether big picture sort of blue sky
thinking is just just pretty tough or
something else I don't know
well I think it's like you know Plato's
Republic right the the ideal government
is a philosopher-king democracies are
messy and extremely slow and most people
really shouldn't be making political
decisions for other people right but
it's like the best worst system and a
you know I purely a super benevolent
hyper-rational dictator would be a far
superior form of government than like
what we have in the States but since we
can't guarantee that anybody you put in
that position is going to be that like
hyper rational reasonable person you
need all of these other like checks and
things and so I feel like that's sort of
what happens with the whole
centralization decentralization argument
is you'll get these rapid swings in
either direction where the internet
started out super decentralized and kind
of a free-for-all Wild West and then
power started you know coming in to
certain areas right like Google Facebook
whatnot
and now we're seeing the extremes of
that and saying like alright this is too
much and so it's gonna swing back in the
other direction if Ian like maybe we
will get this you know Internet 3.0
crypto net whatever yeah that people are
asking for but that too I think will be
temporary and it's something about that
you know cuz like here's the thing with
total decentralization is like stuff
needs a plan right like you if you
imagine like laying out a city or
designing the streets by committee and
just like completely ad-hoc with the
planning or like it to get mess you want
a powerful body for certain things yeah
so it's I think that you know we'll
maybe we'll swing towards
decentralization and then that will be
dissatisfying in its ways and we'll
swing back towards you know concentrated
power and like we're just always going
to be in those kinds of cycles yeah I
think so the grass always tends to be
greener as well and people presume that
the huge is going to make some sort of
improvement if they just make a drastic
change which I don't know it doesn't
seem to be the case
you touched on something there about the
benevolent single dictator thing and I
always think about how crazy is that I
know that you you write those checks
below Donald Trump or the the prime
minister or whoever it might be the head
of any particular state there are checks
and there's people around there culpable
too and processes they need to follow
but at the end of the day the person
that presses the button that nukes
another country is just a guy and like
that person is completely at the mercy
of all of their biases and all of their
prejudices and everything that they've
got and the fact that we've got seven
billion people on the planet at the
mercy of that like I know that it is the
you know it would appear to be the
system that is the best at the moment
but looking at it totally objectively it
it makes me laugh and also be terrified
in the same sentence yeah you know I
would have felt more that way three
years ago mmm but I actually think that
Trump has been really good for the like
American sense of democracy because if
anybody like sits down and tries to make
a list of all the ways their life is
worse with Trump being president it's
gonna be a very short list right like I
really can't come up with a few things
that are the direct responsibility of
like Trump policies that have affected
me on an individual level and like the
country is still going pretty well right
like I would agree the international
policy and stir like a national
relations and things like that have
taken a hit but I think everybody was
like so terrified of what would happen
with this you know seemingly insane
person being in power and the answer is
like not much right like the the tariff
stuff now kind of sucks because I mean
like we sell tea right and our tea
prices went up 25% importing of China
but like the these are all kind of like
edge Kaycee things right it's not like
we got to some crazy nuclear war with
North Korea it's not like you know there
are Nazis marching in the street like I
think some people legitimately thought
might happen right like president has
actually remarkably little influence on
our lives and that should be kind
refreshing for how much we allow
ourselves to get wrapped up in the
insanity of some of that political stuff
yeah you are right do you think that
people are very quick to personify these
roles obviously their main actual
problem was with Donald Trump's
personality I think there was a NBC or
maybe one of them or maybe like a vice
news article or something a video that
they did online where they went around
before the election and they were
showing particular campaign objectives
and particular policies that was it to
voters from the opposite side and saying
this is what this is a Hillary policy
blah blah blah and they're going yeah
yeah brilliant classic Hillary classic
love it love it and then at the end they
got actually all of those of Donald
Trump and you could see the cognitive
dissonance occur the policy but that
with the the NPC programming just like
triggers so is that because we've got
you know like The Bachelor and and like
Pop Idol equivalents and stuff like that
where everything is personified and it's
all about the person's narrative and
story and that often can actually
detract away from the objective measures
yeah I mean I think that's part of it I
think too like humans are inherently
tribal and we need some tribe to feel a
part of and most and also importantly I
think we need some tribe to be an enemy
of right yeah and if you and I actually
think that it's a useful exercise to
think about you're like what tribes you
choose to identify with and then which
tribes you choose to like fight against
you know intellectually or emotionally
or like what will you allow yourself to
be triggered by is kind of a worthwhile
exercise because if you don't pick what
you're what's going to be like your
enemy then your friends or your
community or like whatever news you let
through your filter is gonna pick it for
you and like politics is just the
easiest one all right it's super easy to
hang out with all of your liberal or
conservative friends
and like [ __ ] on the other team yeah in
the same way that you know you'll just
[ __ ] on the other like sports team and
you're like dope almost nobody argue
about politics has any impact in the
political sphere at all right like
everybody getting uppity about the news
like it doesn't affect your life like
it's not gonna change how you behave day
to day like you're not gonna go do
anything about it like this thing that
you're getting so pissed about it's not
gonna like you're like you're not gonna
do anything you're not gonna run for
office you're not gonna go like petition
at the local courthouse or whatever it's
a get something change you're just gonna
like [ __ ] about it on Facebook's it's
like it's it's just a fun bonding thing
more than anything right and it's a way
to show that you're a member of the
group because everyone's always trying
to feel out what tribes all the other
people around them are in and a really
easy way to show what tribe you're in is
like how you feel about political stuff
right yeah because it downstream from
that it suggests that there's more
implications people can draw about your
personality I was speaking to Caleb
Caleb Jones the other day who's a
massive non-monogamy advocate and he
said you know non-monogamy leans left
lots of libertarian friends but doesn't
smoke weed doesn't drink and for his
other friends that's like what you don't
smoke well they cook they can't believe
the fact that he doesn't smoke weed
because it doesn't fit the profile yeah
we do but Green he was saying about how
not not allowing people to put you in a
box and not allowing people to
categorize you sort of one-dimensional
II is one of the best things that you
can do not only to hedge your
personality your interests in life but
also just to come across as a bit more
of an enigma and a bit more of a
multi-layered multifaceted interesting
individual I don't think anyone wants to
look back in their life and feel like it
was a trope or a cur like a cliche I my
life was really good I was a caricature
of myself yeah
well and if you can tell anybody one or
two of your political geeks and they can
accurately infer all the other ones
you probably haven't thought about what
you believe in very much right you've
just sort of accepted like the package
set of ideas that come with one group
and you're running with them yeah right
and I think like you know there's all of
these there's a lot of really hot-button
issues that I think most people don't
think about very hard like guns and
abortion are the two big ones where if
you actually sit down and think about
them like they're really really tough
like things to design policies around
because they both require drawing sort
of an arbitrary line in the sand that's
not based in you know really anything
beyond your emotions or you're like
philosophical of religious background
and I think people like to think that
they're super cut and dry easy things
but the only way you would think that is
if again you hadn't thought about them
very hard
it's like going off of what your group
is supposed to believe yeah I think
people often talk past each other with
these issues as well right like on the
topic of gun control
one group is talking about school
shootings and people who are on SSRIs
and the other side is talking about an
armed militia against a government a
tyrannical government or on the topic of
abortion one side is talking about
protecting a woman's rights if she's
been raped and the other side is talking
about late term you know 20 weeks in
abortions with no no reason other than
personal choice so that the actual
discussions aren't the questions that
each side opposing to each other aren't
even the same one they're talking from I
think they're actually I think actually
harder than that I think that you can be
a lot more generous to the other side's
on both of those arguments right and I
think that the most generous way to
frame the gun control debate is like why
or how can you say that a poor single
mother living in the slums of Chicago is
not allowed to defend herself
right like that to me
seems insane if you're surrounded by
people with guns and you want to tell
these law-abiding citizens who are
living in terrible areas that they can't
have an equivalent weapon with which to
defend themselves right that seems crazy
and then in the abortion case it's not
even I think about the late choice well
it's it's partly that one side is saying
this is a choice debate and so they're
saying that anybody against abortion
it's against women having rights which
is insane and then the other side is
saying this is a life discussion in
anybody who's pro-abortion is Pro murder
right and that's also kind of like an
insane framing and so if both sides
continue to like talk past each other it
doesn't get anywhere but until somebody
sits down and they say like you know
either
at this date or at this line fetus
becomes a human and then it's no longer
okay to aboard that's the only way you
can be okay with like abortion at some
level and I really this is something
that I think about a lot like I don't
know where the rules on it should be
like I'm very I'm very pro-choice but I
don't have like a good I think
backing up for that position it just
feels like emotionally right that the
the right to choose is more important
than the philosophical discussion about
when life begins but I also recognize
that like I don't have a super solid
backing for that all right I agree and I
have it having watched Ben Shapiro's
anti abortion debate videos on YouTube I
found myself putting myself on the other
side of the fence trying to put my point
across to Ben and finding that I was
getting absolutely annihilated like I
just I didn't have an awful lot of come
back other than sort of her body her
choice I guess and yeah this arbitrary
line in the sand of when life begins in
quotation marks and unfortunately you
can't even really talk about this
there's no really any of us all is this
ya know because the minute you say that
there could be a reasonable argument for
the other side you're like labeled as
you know a terrible person it doesn't
really matter which side you're doing
that
- right like you've got a group of super
liberal people and you say like well
actually I can see why somebody would
think that life begins at conception
without religion like the immediate
reaction is that like oh you don't think
women should have rights right and like
that's such an insane
mischaracterization of what someone's
trying to say that it closes the door to
any discussion yeah and you know on the
same side if you like tell a super
conservative group they're like oh well
I actually think that you know there is
some reasonable allowance for you know
abortion and in certain cases like the
same things gonna happen right like then
you're obviously a murderer who wants to
like kill babies and that's not fair
either we've just sort of lost ability I
think to talk about these things or to
risk talking about them in polite
discussion it's like just not worth it
anymore so we talked about Game of
Thrones and then people just riff on
Game of Thrones and they say that the
most recent that was [ __ ] so final two
books not will do click Freya if our
final two books ah to do I would say mmm
find a good one here with 240 to choose
from I imagine that's probably not
actually that easy of a choice yeah my
favorite kid here well if you guys so
I've got all of my notes ordered by
rating up on my site so if you go to
like NAT Eliason comm slash inlets you
can see them all but all throw a doubt
gödel Escher Bach is amazing is sorry
it's a gödel Escher Bach okay by douglas
hofstadter he was one of like the early
pioneers in terms of thought and AI
space and it's it's one of the most
intellectually challenging books i think
i've ever read the writing writing is
very easy right it's not difficult ly
written but it requires like grasping
and trying to work with ideas from like
math physics logic biology and also
these like tricky philosophical ideas
about what is a brain what is it mind
like is there an eye all of that
and it's written in this extremely
beautiful style that merges artwork by
MC Escher narrative little fables in a
style of like Lewis Carroll and then
more more like descriptive nonfiction
writing that brings it all together it's
a very cool book there's really no other
book quite like it that's awesome that
sounds really really cool would you
recommend is kindle sufficient for that
Oh does it need to be the physical copy
I think there is a Kindle version and if
there is I wouldn't recommend it I would
definitely read the physical version so
that you get all the art laid out
properly so it's like there's so a lot
of the ideas in it come back to this
idea of like strange loops and recursive
relationships between ideas or functions
and a computer things like that and so
some of the narratives are themselves
recursive and nested in these odd ways
that require you to see the physical
layout in the book I totally get what's
going on I think on ik and it would be
really hard yeah I got you and then last
one I'll throw out would be denial of
death by Ernest Becker
that's another super interesting one
it's basically just about what it sounds
like that almost everything we do is
about or is in some way related to our
uncomfortableness with death and trying
to create you know these pyramids these
sculptures that will outlast us at our
in our in our feeble attempts at
immortality so I was speaking to Kyle
cederstrom do you know Carl he was the
guy who guy who did he optimized one
area of his life every month for a year
he basically immersed himself in like
the life hacking world and he optimized
one one month with sex one month was
money one month was productivity one
month of site relationships or fitness
or whatever it might be and his sequel
book which was about happiness and he
said he was pretty much certain the
overarching principle between both books
was that the reason people are trying to
optimize their life so hard and the
reason that people are searching for
happiness is in an effort to
Dave off their thoughts about death and
it sounds it's such a morbid like bottom
line to put to a book but I do think
there I do think that our fear of the
end drives so much of what people do I
mean obviously like that maximises
evolutionary fitness right like being
afraid of death is is generally over the
the course of our evolution a pretty
good thing to have all right now in a
world of abundance it leads to some
pretty some odd some odd thought loops
occurring yeah seriously
for sure that's a good one for
ruminating on that thought so roles as
well not I can't thank you enough man
it's been awesome if you will ever spend
a lot of fun give us the time in the
future maybe we can get you back on do
another top five or something like that
as always the links to everything that
we've spoken about today will be in the
show notes below I'll also make sure
that I add every book that I can find
from that not to gone through today and
I'll put it on our Amazon shop front
just follow the link and you can support
the podcast at no extra cost to yourself
through that also links to made you
think podcast growth machine and that
socials will be down below as well so
make sure that you go and check them out
I highly recommend made you think it's
fantastic podcast nap today's been sick
man thank you very much yeah thanks
Chris
[Music]
you